you just said one of the biggest
possible victories you could have when
the supreme court ruled that uh
you guys can keep your places of worship
open not just the jewish community but
all the religious communities are now
allowed to well they were always allowed
to right and cuomo was directly in
violation of the constitution
and he made an executive order now after
we won the court cases oh the executive
order expired
but here's my problem he's going to
create a new executive order december
1st to override this
supreme court order and he's going to
win and here's the problem he can say
whatever i do
i am the boss mr cuomo i i can't
threaten to beat you up because i'll get
in trouble with tim and i'll get in
trouble with the cops but if you ever
want to take off the governor title
pop over to beau park brooklyn pop up to
my third floor
let's go man-to-man i know you can kick
my butt but when i'm done with you baby
you'll be crying too sanction your
sanction official
not mike tyson it's going to be from
benson street for the kids
he's a big tough guy i know he'll beat
me up but i just want him to feel the
pain
i want him to see my neighbor he he's
scared to come to our neighborhood he's
scared the man
is scared to come and here's the big
thing i i'm i'm telling you that i have
my wedding holes open
i have all of them open we're hiding
we're doing it in sneaky but i'm going
to weddings one month i went to 17
weddings
i have little children in schools in the
dark i promise you in the dark
learning because they're scared of the
sheriffs coming in to shut them down
special needs mothers that are having
nervous breakdowns i had a lady commit
suicide two and a half weeks ago
she couldn't take it she couldn't take
it you how do you have an autistic child
you think you don't need a break
you think you don't have a special needs
child that needs daily care to go to the
thing the kid himself is gonna have a
nervous breakdown
we had one kid that we had to take him
three times to the hospital
with all the problems we have in the
world and you're just making it worse
because you think you're saving lives
more dying because of him
he's lying he has he's a fool
and i'm telling you i'm so pissed i'll
go back to jail whatever it takes
to protect my fellow man and it's not
for new york it's office 12
i'll be representing all of new york
city even though i'll be elected by my
community
but i'll be representing the country i
want the people to know
stand up don't be scared of that idiot
governor in los angeles who himself
had a party the governor of new jersey
twice
the governor of new jersey goes out to
dinner with the family no problem and
everybody's screaming at him and the
best part is new york city had a
birthday party a birthday party for
somebody
with 20 30 of the politicians and we
said hey we caught you and they said oh
there's only six of us here
we said are you crazy look around here
are pictures we saw 20 30 of you oh they
were coming and going
rules for thee but not for me exactly
that's tyranny right so i want you to
know
i am not scared of him if you're scared
of him coming i will be your shield
new york city we're going to stand up
we're going to fight back i want the
rest of the country to fight back
don't be scared what can they do to you
give you a ticket
put you in jail for a day most likely
the little towns to sheriff are you
neighbors
and if you have some kind of a bully
there let's let's call them out let's
call somebody from other towns
i'm getting you know antifa threatened
me i don't know if you know who they are
oh of course
yeah they did it through instagram they
sent some message we're going to come
get you
and who else came after me wait wait
wait hold hold on hold on
you're you're challenging authoritarian
government edict
that's our some of it uh with the
supreme court willing been proven to be
a violation of your rights
and the anti-fascists are threatening
you
because again they're allowed to protest
we can't and again i'm for trump and
they're for biden whatever so they
threatened me and there was one more
organization to threaten me
i forgot what it was and i posted it all
over the place and i said i'm not scared
of the mayor i'm not scared of antifa
come to my house again i'm not scared of
you what can you do to me you got one
go ahead you got one down i'm not that
important and then i got so much love
from nevada
from idaho from jersey from california
we're gonna come protect you
i had a group of guys that just said
we're coming to your house now ashley to
watch you i i i
have police officers that came to my
house and asked me to sign an
autograph for their mother they were
embarrassed that i was arrested their
mother screamed at them
i am a guy that is just my neighbor and
i know
that that suffering we do suffer enough
we all have issues in our families we
all have problems
you know my sister is down syndrome and
i've been taking care of her
for the last 43 years since my father
passed away
and she's beautiful she prays for me
every day because she says i'm going to
hell
i'm no good and she has more money than
me by the way
all women have more money than me what
the hell's wrong with me 10. you must
not be working hard i'm not working hard
i'm not a good man but my show is not
doing well either
i'm joking with you but you know guys
hey
calm i'm desperate right now i'm dead
meat but
i'm telling you the love of your fellow
man
is more important than anything and i
know some of you gonna say i'm preaching
this is what i've done for 30 years
whether you like it or not whether you
want to knock me or not people are not
telling me oh
hell she we saw you cheating on your
wife my wife was sitting in the car when
you heard the message
you're doing drugs again you can't catch
me on anything because i know who i am
i'm not going to lie to you you want me
to wear my suit and tie you want me to
sand straight you know they called me
into the office of the politicians
i walk around my shirt on top my jacket
i'm wearing a suit and tie for you tim i
thought you were going to
dress up tonight no no i know anyways
and my wife bought this ugly tie i'm
going to burn it on the way out
no it doesn't matter i hate you you look
great it's bad
she paid 55 bucks is she crazy nice
can you get me to be in i'm joking which
i love you here
you're so handsome thanks thanks
just sitting here you're yelling at him
i know i don't know why i think it's the
medication get it out
i love you you're you're governor rage
on right i am
you know but i want you to know that
this is what i do and they
sat me down you're gonna wear a suit and
tie you're gonna follow the rules you're
gonna talk normal listen to me
this is who i am if the people of my
community want to elect me and you elect
me who i am
i will fight for you who i am when you
know on i was telling you
before on the city council we have a
channel called the city council channel
very boring they scratch their behinds
they pick the nose you want to die at
the end of the four hours really you
actually want to cut your wrists
when i get it to city council everybody
tune in watch baby
here comes round two i'm gonna blow the
city council that's gonna be the number
one show on town
i'm gonna make them miserable i'm not
gonna let them pass illegal laws you
know they read one
one route one paragraph blurbs and they
vote on a bill
which is 40 50 pages long 30 of them a
month
you know what this is for too long the
american people have kind of just sat
back and
hit the d button or the r button or
check d or check r and you end up with a
bunch of politicians who just want the
job but don't want to do it
so they get elected because well they're
probably not good at anything else so
hey convince some people to vote for you
you get a salary you get a job you can
have power you can you know
shake hands kiss babies and all that
stuff and then go and sit down and do
nothing
and as long as nothing was happening no
one cared everything moved along
now that we're actually facing a real
crisis
and these uh these mayors these
governors
are well i'm gonna say it i think andrew
cuomo murdered six thousand five hundred
people this is a story from propublica
he he ordered six coveted patients into
nursing homes
and this was back several months ago
propublica reported on this
they said is around 6 500 or so uh
seniors
died of kovid because of andrew cuomo
and he's not the only governor that did
it
so you've got these people doing this
outright insane
i mean stupidity it's he killed these
people
so i want to tell you most of these
nursing homes get money from the
government
so they were willing to take these
patients back and i screamed at a lot of
them i even have a relatives in the
business
and he says well we're understaffed i
said if you're understaffed then shut
down the business or get more people
it's not only for the profit lives are
not profitable
so there was one jewish boy had a
nursing home in jersey
and he told the governor drop dead i'm
not taking the people back
i don't care about you we're going to
find you we're going to close you down
he says no problem i'm not going to let
people die in my place
he was one of the only ones that had
nobody die in his nursing home
governor cuomo we had 1400 people die in
my hospital
my hospital is made you go there you're
sick you get some medicine you go home
it's not a place to be incubated or be
taking you know forever to get better
these guys are not trained remember some
of them are residents they're beginning
nurses i go there i see it you can't
overcrowd them they're not competent as
it is sometimes
they're overloaded with nothing you're
shoving them in there they don't know
what they're doing
people for two days didn't have water i
had a guy in my office crying at his
father
they wouldn't let you know they don't
let us visit the nursing home still to
this day but the hospitals
let's go there was one guy in the
hospital when they wouldn't let him in
there
for two days with no food or water the
man was crying finally he was able to
get his
phone and he cried to his son please
come in there they took away his phone
we found the phone in jersey and he was
died the next day
they said covered when we knew that it
was hunger and thirst is this a true
story there's nothing you can do because
i have the boy you came to the protest
with me to the hospital
they killed his father and it's not one
i have many stories like this one after
the next after the next
the mayor and governor are two we have
so many politicians i'm not talking one
we have 51 councilman 300 assemblymen
500 state senators and i'll go down the
list of how many community board leaders
and so on and nobody's standing up to
these two winners
nobody's standing up and saying stop mr
governor mayor his liaisons are walking
around threatening us you know the mayor
said
no funerals and when when people die no
mornings
he went to the big rabbi who he tried to
shut down the big rabbi's wedding
he went to them when the rabbi died one
of their brothers died he went to the
morning there was no social distancing
there
you can't go into somebody else's house
when there's covert especially if
somebody just died in the house
again he broke his own law and of course
his liaison which is one of my people
i'm ashamed to tell you
the to the jewish liaison to the
community is kissing the mayor's behind
and he's he's giving up his people so he
can get a salary my councilman get a
hundred eighty thousand dollar salary
for each committee they sit on they get
thirty to forty thousand dollars they
sit on seven committees now forget you
have to do an eight hour day
plus you have to do seven committees
plus you have to run around meet people
plus you have to collect money these
guys seem to be able to pass laws
make all this money they get 350 380 000
by the end of the year
they get a million one for office
expenses a million five to give out to
their favorite charities or donations
that means ian if you have like a little
sweater company and you're giving to the
poor people some of the sweaters we'll
give you twenty thousand dollars that's
how it works
now after all that they still get
another sixty nine dollars a day for
lunch money or stipend i don't even know
what that is
you know and this keeps going and going
so we'll we'll down 150 million dollars
before we blink
just with the 51 councilman forget the
community boys then you have
commissioners
of five different agencies department of
buildings department of health i'm going
to go through 312 of them i'm not
department of sanitation department of
finance and of course the
uh hpd department each one has
commissioners in every borough each one
has chiefs if one
have duplicate jobs and then you have
all your inspectors combine them
work them up we can save a billion
dollars just in that money
idiots and and each each agency fights
with each agency
i know but each agency fights with each
agency to put stuff through a department
of buildings
you have to go through the department of
health then you have to go through the
department of finance and each one can
take three to four to five months
do you know how long it takes to get a
set of plans approved today in new york
city
about six to eight months so you're
paying mortgage on your house you can't
walk kick cash because if you do any
work you get a 10
15 000 penalty plus they don't let you
if you didn't work without a house to
get another permit for another year
you're being punished we're like little
kids we get punished and it just gets
worse and worse then when you have to
all your paperwork
now you have to go to the parks
department to get a tree plant in front
of your house
which is only plant twice a year so now
you can't even move into your house till
you get a stupid tree
and here's the best part you paid all
your fines you did everything correctly
you now have to verify the last thing on
your list is to verify your address
it's called topo a one small agency that
cost you a hundred bucks
they've been closed for the last eight
months so you can't get your dress
verification
you're screwed so so uh and this is just
one little bit of red tape
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you